dramatique incendie hier soir à bléré le
feu a pris sous les toits d'un immeuble
de deux étages dans le centre ville un
corps a été découvert dans l'un des
appartements au rez de chaussée le
magasin est resté portes closes
aujourd'hui par mesure de sécurité
l' enquête a été confiée à la brigade de
gendarmerie de bléré sur place three
stories cli
il est 22 heures environ lorsque cet
immeuble situé au 38 rue du pont à bléré
prend feu un corps est alors retrouvée
sans être formellement identifié ce
gérant d'un bar du centre ville
interpellé par une odeur de plastique
brûlé a donné l' alerte on est sorti on
a essayé de voir d'où ça venait on m'a
parlé avec deux trois clients qui
étaient ici et on a vu une petite fumée
sortir de là très rapidement on était
voir jeu il se trouve que je savais
qu'ils habitaient là et
donc j'ai essayé de l'appeler j'attends
je voyais que ça répondait pas on a fait
tout de suite les pompiers il ya deux
jeunes qui ont essayé de monter dans
l'immeuble voir mais le problème c'est
que ces détails et c'était voilà quoi
c'était quasiment à respirer spira bhl
dans le petit immeuble
lorsque les pompiers arrivent sur place
des flammes de plusieurs mètres de
hauteur surgissent du toit immédiatement
par crainte d'une propagation les
habitants à proximité sont évacués
rapidement maîtrisé l'incendié se serait
éteint vers 4 heures du matin la partie
haute de l'habitation a été ravagé par
les flammes les dégâts se sont étendus
jusqu au rez-de-chaussée dans ce petit
commerce
infiltrations d'eau et puis les odeurs
de fumée donc voilà notamment sur tous
les saints chiites raft maintenant va
falloir qu on étudie comment on peut
venir en aide aux magasins qui a été
touchée qui seront dans l'incapacité de
rouvrir ses portes évidemment tout de
suite l'occupant du premier étage a pu
être relogée chez ses voisins les
origines de l'incendié seront déterminés
par l' enquête aucune hypothèse n'est
avancée